المفصل
ليس فصلا دراسيا في مدرسه ولكنها حصه
اللغه العربيه في احد مراكز الدروس
الخصوصيه التي يتوافق عليها مئات الطلبه
والطالبات يوميا لتحصيل الدروس في كافه
المواد الدراسيه بعضهم مثل اسراء الطالبه
في الصف الاول الثانويه التي فضلت الذهاب
للمركز مكتفيه به اما الاخرون مثل الايمان
وعمر وماريز ما زالوا يواضبون على الذهاب
الى المدرسه الى جانب المركز
احسن من المدرسه
احلى بيضيع الوقت في المدرسه
يعني المدرسه برده من اولوياتك الدروس
الخصوصيه ومشكله مزمنه تضع عبئا ماديا على
الاسر المصريه فعلى مدى عقود حاولت
الحكومات المتعاقبه حل هذه المشكله فبعكس
الحرب التي شنها وزير التعليم السابق على
مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه اقترح الوزير
الحالي امام مجلس النواب ترخيص وتقنين
المراكز الامر الذي اثار جدلا كبيرا هو
غير قانوني وفي نفس الوقت ده حاجه مخليه
الواحد طبعا هو شغال مش عارف ممكن
النهارده يحصل ايه بكره يحصل ايه دي حاجه
بالنسبه لي انا بتبقى مخلياني انا شغال مش
مرتاح في نفس الوقت الطالب برده مش مرتاح
انا ممكن في اي وقت طب مستقبلا انا اعمل
فيه ايه المدرسه تف المدرسه طول العمر
منظومه تعليميه ابني اتعلم اصل هي مش
المدرسه تعليم بس انا بعلمه نظام حياه
المدرسه اصلا ما لهاش دور اللي هي المدرسه
ما لهاش الا العيال بتتقيد بالاسم هناك
وبس اه بسبب الجدل الذي اثاره المقترح طلب
الوزير بحوار مجتمعي لتقنين الدروس
الخصوصيه التي تصل فاتورهتها الى سبعه
واربعين مليار جنيه لا تعلم عنها الحكومه
شيئا مقترحا استخدام الموارد منها مستقبلا
في رفع رواتب المعلمين ودعم المدارس
الحكوميه التي تعاني من كثافه الفصول ونقص
عدد المعلمين وانخفاض رواتبهم وضمان بيئه
تعليميه امنه خاضعه لرقابه حكوميه
ولا نعلم حجما المشكله في عدد طلاب
المدارس في مصر يصل الى نحو خمسه وعشرين
مليون طالب 90% منهم في مدارس حكوميه فيما
يصل عدد المعلمين الى اقل من مليون وبرغم
زياده موازنه التعليم في الموازنه العامه
للدوله الا انها تظل اقل من ما هو مطلوب
لخفض العجز في المعلمين او القضاء على
ظاهره الدروس الخصوصيه راندا ابو العزم
العربيه القاهره